you never stand up for your what of
course we stand up for Europe but you
seem to live in a parallel universe here
I don't let's not be silly please the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization NATO
has just had its 70th birthday but it
wasn't a happy one constant carping by
Donald Trump about defense spending has
caused bitter resentment here in Europe
my guest this week here at NATO
headquarters is Rose Gottemoeller the
organization's Deputy Secretary General
will she now acknowledge that NATO has
serious splits in its unity
[Music]
Rose gotta mullah welcome to conflict
zone thank you it's great to be here
your boss yen Stoltenberg reminded the
world recently that NATO's mission was
to provide credible deterrence and
defense the fact is that deterrence is
no longer credible and hasn't been for a
long time has it yeah why do you say
that well not in the midst of war well I
say that because just five months ago
America's national defense strategy
Commission painted a pretty dismal
picture of the us's ability to protect
both itself and his allies the security
and well-being of the US it said are a
greater risk today than at any time in
decades
America's superiority has eroded to a
dangerous degree in its ability to
defend this allies its partners and its
own vital interests is increasingly in
doubt that's that's dismal isn't it
there are many different views of how
deterrence and defense are conducted
today and I think for NATO the emphasis
truly has to be on what we now call the
hybrid challenges that are coming at us
many of them associated with emergence
of new technologies and accelerated by
new technology let's look at Defense
Commission factored those into its
report the US military could suffer
unacceptably high casualties and the
loss of major our capital assets in its
next conflict it might struggle to win a
war against Russia or China that's good
that's not good news is it well what I
have to tell you if you ask me the
question about whether deterrence is
working or not I have to say yes because
we do in fact here at NATO work together
as 29 nations with the United States to
provide for the deterrence and defense
of all twenty-nine allies and we do have
challenges I don't want to sugarcoat the
challenges that we face and particularly
the challenges emanating from new
technology but I'm not ready to cry that
we're in the midst of disaster the
secretary pointed out that for the first
time NATO has combat ready battle groups
in the eastern part of the Alliance for
battle groups in the Baltic States and
Poland plus additional forces amounting
to a brigade the authoritative RAND
Corporation doesn't think much of that
either it says NATO forces are not
nearly sufficient to defend a contiguous
line until
a large-scale conventional advance by a
mechanized adversary such as Russia
again hardly a vote of confidence in the
measures that NATO has taken is it the
for battle groups in the Baltic States
and in Poland are not meant to hold the
line for long they are precisely that
they aren't to be credible they are they
are credible as a deterrence and defense
tripwire because they bring together
forces from across the Alliance units
from every single NATO ally practically
are serving in those battle groups
Russia knows Russia knows that if they
step across the line they will face the
entire NATO alliance but that is why
nowadays we are placing our emphasis on
reinforcement and readiness and being
able to rapidly move troops in behind
those battles it says that given NATO's
current posture and capability including
the European battalions and rotational
us armored Brigade Combat Team Russia
still enjoys a substantial time distance
advantage in the initial days and weeks
of a conventional ground campaign the
Baltic States that's the reality of Geo
of geography and the fact that Russia
does in fact sit as the great land power
in Eurasia that's a fact of history but
I know forces are not providing the
deterrence that you promised I don't
know why you keep saying that Tim sorry
yes sorting some reports that have come
out and I'm terribly amused by those
rand reports you know I worked for Rand
in the 1980s they said exactly the same
thing during the Cold War so the fact of
the matter is they don't make it up but
they are repeating you know what is
based on a reality of the geopolitics
and the geography of Eurasia what we can
do is ensure that Russia knows all
twenty-nine allies are prepared to act
and are prepared to reinforce and that
has proven during the Cold War an
effective deterrent and I believe it
proves an effective deterrent today the
impression of an alliance that is no
longer credible has been assisted if you
like by years of war games played out on
computers by the Pentagon
range of Defense experts NATO
consistently loses against what it
considers to be its main adversary
doesn't it well I think the best thing
you can say about exercises of all kinds
is that they are meant to stress test
stress test until we understand where
our weaknesses lie and what we have to
do better
I was present this fall when we had our
big Trident juncture exercise which was
not a computer exercise it was a big
combined arms exercise in Norway and it
showed that it had been a long time
since the alliance had reinforced across
the North Atlantic there were problems
that emerged in the eye of the bull well
we saw the end of the Soviet Union and
everyone decided and it was a good thing
the last tank of the United States left
Europe in 2013 we saw that as a good
thing but then after 2014 and the
aggression against Crimea the seizure of
Crimea the destabilization of the
Donbass we had to think again about
deterrence and defense that must be an
urgency mustn't there because last month
give you an example a senior researcher
at the Center for a New American
Security Davidoff Manik who you probably
know I know graphically that when the
simulations were run against Russia and
China America get its backside gets its
backside handed to it he put it slightly
differently I've just adjusted it we
usually fail he added to achieve our
objective of preventing aggression by
the adversary do you think Moscow hasn't
noticed that as well well I do think
it's important as I said to train an
exercise without taking our eye off the
ball and when we learn that we have
problems then we have to rectify them
and that means a lot of hard work but
we're in the midst of it it's
extraordinary that you do have these
problems because the staggering amount
by which NATO countries outspend Russia
on defense and still lose the war games
is surprising isn't it really when you
think that the Alliance's combines
economic strength in 2016 was about 31
times that of Russia's what are you
going with the money if you're not
getting value for money are you I'm
asking the question
to whether the problems you described
are actually the problems that you have
I'd be very interested to see how the
Russian general staff trains and
exercises I'm sure they also train to
stress themselves until they fail and
then they have to work on their problems
so I think we have to consider what the
challenges on both sides are and in the
case of NATO and its allies the United
States and its allies
I see capable forces that are adjusting
to the modern warfare and are moving
rather I would say flexibly and with
speed to do so I'm not always sure I see
that in the Russian Armed Forces despite
a nicer advantage of more than three
quarters of a trillion dollars spent by
the Alliance's combined military forces
in a single year I'm talking about 2015
you would struggle to win a conflict
with Russia how is that possible when
you out spend them to this enormous
degree well again I'm not accepting the
basis of your hypothesis I'm not sure
that we would actually lose because
again we have a great deal of
flexibility and adaptability
that's why NATO has succeeded all these
years we have been able to adapt to new
challenges when they come at us you
think it's succeeding with 2008 the
Russians took a bite out of Georgia
after a lightning strike I know wasn't a
NATO member there was a NATO partner in
2014 in Crimea you mentioned yeah they
moved in seized it since 2014 Russian
forces either regular or contract troops
have been operating with pretty near
impunity in eastern Ukraine 10,000
people have died so NATO's claim that
it's been keeping the peace isn't quite
true is it I think it is important to
point out that article 5 of The
Washington treaty applies to allies
that's the famous all for one and one
for all part of the Washington treaty
that is the core of our defense alliance
where Georgia is concerned in 2008 that
was an enormous wake-up call and 2014
represented a sea change for the
Alliance not even see it coming not
really in terms of a wake up call in
Ukraine but also the fact
- the rise of ISIL and the establishment
of the Caliphate and Mosel that year
brought the fight against terrorism and
violent extremism into sharper focus as
well so we did have a wake-up call in
that period and I think it has led to
huge change in the Alliance not least of
which was a huge change in our defense
spending and look at what we really need
today to counter both of these kinds of
challenges but despite the fact that you
provide Ukraine with what Ian
Stoltenberg called strong political and
practical support it makes no difference
to what Russia's moves are in the
military field in that area as it it
strengthened its naval forces it's built
up its tanks according to the chief of
staff Ukrainian General Staff last year
they built up tanks along the border
they're not being deterred by your
strong support political or otherwise
for Ukraine are they I think they've
taken notice we have put quite a bit
into training but I want to give credit
to the Ukrainian Armed Forces themselves
they have been doing a lot to
professionalize and develop their
capability and capacity over the the
last six years that has really been
impressive and so they working together
with us and also with individual NATO
allies have been making a difference to
hold the line but you continue to dangle
NATO membership as a carrot in front of
them without giving them a timetable for
it without a timetable it's meaningless
isn't it yeah well let's have a moment
to talk about that in 2008 at the
Bucharest summit four countries spoke
about their aspirations and NATO agreed
that they would be in the line to have
NATO membership those countries included
Ukraine and Georgia but we have been
very clear that both of those countries
are still on the path of reform we have
to ensure that when countries are ready
to enter NATO's door they are ready to
contribute to security and defense in
the Alliance but also to come up to
certain standards of democratic
principles so what are you waiting for
until Moscow has taken another bite out
of eastern Ukraine no what we are
waiting for is to see them come up to a
certain level of readiness for NATO
membership NATO allies have reiterated
in starbug said a decision we made some
years ago that Ukraine will become a
member of NATO
that's the Bucharest summit decision
that still stands at some point at some
time it's up to Ukraine to decide who
their security relationships will be
with that's an important principle from
our perspective I have to say though
it's also very important that all NATO
allies be ready to accept them and that
means seeing a level of reform and
development in their not only Armed
Forces but also in their democratic
practice let's talk about NATO's 70th
birthday which is just kind of God it
wasn't the happiest one downgraded to
foreign minister level instead of the
usual Heads of Government you disagree
on many issues you know Secretary
General hardly ideal in an alliance that
claims its strength rests on unity is it
the Secretary General had a wonderful
speech before a joint session of
Congress the first time any leader of an
international organization has had that
honor it was a great day but we haven't
finished with our celebrations Tim there
will be a leaders meeting at the end of
the year in London in December heads of
state and government will celebrate
NATO's 70th anniversary let me put it
bluntly the problem is that many member
states don't trust Donald Trump do they
and his commitment to NATO and why
should they
I mean he's done everything he could to
undermine trust that he's a hundred
percent behind it you know I haven't
seen that clearly Donald Trump has
shaken things up there's no question
about it he's gotten all it's a bit more
than that he's gotten all the allies to
sit up and take notice because he was
very concerned about the lack of fair
burden-sharing inside the Alliance and
he wanted allies to pay more in his
inimitable way he got everybody to pay
attention to the necessity of putting
more money into their defence budgets
that's something
the funding in a minute but I want to
just say that ten days ago it fell to
William burns former State Department
adviser to five US presidents and one of
the most respected US diplomats over the
last 30 years to point out the Trump's
unilateralism is doing Vladimir Putin's
work for him by widening the gap between
the US and Europe of a climate change
Iran brexit and NATO that's a serious
charge from a serious highly placed
person Burns is indeed very serious yes
he is but what's your question why don't
you take that seriously you're telling
me everything's fine I'm telling you
everything's fine but what I say
elephant in every room isn't he he's the
one they talk about he keeps casting
doubt on article 5 on NATO whether it's
obsolete or not you've heard the
statements and you've read the reports
well look in this headquarters we have
important work to do every single day
that's why Trust is so important exactly
trust is broken and that you're in
trouble aren't you we are not in trouble
we are working hard to do what we need
to do in terms of running our operations
in Afghanistan and Iraq in terms of
continuing to run our operations in k4
in the Western Balkans in terms of
providing for both deterrence and
defense and fighting against terrorism
in this alliance so every day we keep
our heads down and keep working yes of
course there are differences among NATO
allies and as I've said mr. Trump has
gotten everybody to sit up and take
notice but this is this is more than
just differences Doug lute former US
ambassador to NATO said earlier this
month this is unprecedented we're at the
70th anniversary but it's the first time
allies have doubted the commitment of
the American President NATO allies he
said see Trump as the Alliance's most
urgent and often most difficult problem
well again highly placed influential
well-informed indeed indeed Doug lute is
as well but I don't need to agree with
all my friends and colleagues on the
outside what I see is how NATO is
working day in day out to make a
difference to our deterrence and defense
and that includes fighting terrorism you
seem to live in a parallel universe I
don't I don't how do you say parallel
House of Representatives they had so
little confidence in Trump's intentions
toward NATO that last year they had to
pass a law with bipartisan support
stating that his US policy to remain a
member of NATO prohibiting funds to be
used to withdraw from the alliance so
little confidence do they have in their
president's commitment to NATO hooray I
saw that as a great expression in
Washington of bipartisan support for
NATO and I saw it when we were there 10
days ago for the 70th anniversary NATO
is well supported across both sides of
the aisle that's a great thing by the
president well I don't know about that
because you know actions speak louder
than words since the president has come
into office the United States is
spending 40 billion dollars more on the
European reassurance initiative putting
more capability and capacity into
Eastern Europe to help in our deterrence
and defense tasks against Russia so I
see the reality and this at the same
time as senior administration officials
told The New York Times on several
occasions last year that the president
had said privately he wanted to withdraw
from NATO and move let's face it that
would destroy the alliance wouldn't it
you think reports like that shedding
doubt on America's and America's
commitment don't damage the Alliance
they do they're corrosive aren't they
well what I would say to you is that
it's perfectly natural for all kinds of
issues to be discussed and debated in
the White House as elsewhere but what we
see is the reality and the practicality
of us support to NATO motto I said
Europe can no longer rely on the United
States and must take destiny into its
own hands so they're not convinced so
that the whole idea is to spread
confidence in NATO and its solidity it's
not happening is it well you know if
uncle amiracle and the other European
Lee
step up and provide more funding and
more capability for the Alliance that's
all - a good thing this gets at this
debate about European defense capability
and European spending on their own
defense hurray I say that's a great idea
it contributes to what NATO needs to do
it doesn't compete with it let's let's
talk about the funding issue because
this Rao / defense spending has gone on
and on he Donald Trump's endlessly
repeated complained that his NATO allies
haven't spent enough on defense and oh
the u.s. a lot of money for the
shortfall which of course is false isn't
it because they don't know the u.s. any
money do they let's clear that up now
shall we it's worth having a bit of
truth about this isn't it well from our
perspective it's been really good that
since we face that watershed year of
2014
every single Ally turned around and
stopped the cuts in defense spending
they don't owe the u.s. let's look at
exactly when we look at let's look at
what the Allies are doing which is
spending their question what I have to
tell you is the way we look at this
question is each Ally should be spending
2% of GDP on defense and 20% of that
amount on acquiring new capability and
capacity defense investment pledge you
never correct these falsehoods do you
there are four suits which Donald Trump
has put on the record which namely that
West European European allies
oh the US a lot of money for the
shortfall the fact is they don't even
doubt the former US ambassador to NATO
said no one owes the u.s. any money
nor is the US spending more because
allies are spending less US defense
spending is a national decision and is
determined by u.s. national security and
defense needs true or false well I think
it's true for every country across the
Alliance that they need to spend what it
is in their interest to spend and that
is on adequate sufficient capability and
capacity they need to get rid of
obsolescent equipment they need to
modernize they need
to train their troops they need to do
what is in their interest for their
defense and that's the most important
thing Tim this is all truth it's a
pretty important thing and you would
think that would be valued a little more
in an alliance and military alliance
which might take 29 countries to war
sometime particularly when the commander
in chief of the largest force says many
country is in NATO owe us a tremendous
amount of money for many years back that
simply is not true if we can't even
acknowledge that then they toast
seriously in trouble isn't it I think we
have perhaps different views of what the
truth is the truth to me is when the
Allies are acquiring real capability and
capacity to contribute to our mutual
defence well on the subject of these
contributions it was left to Germany's
defense minister roseola von der Leyen
to rebuke Trump and reminding him point
in terms it's not just about cash
decency and dependability are also
valuable contributions the clear
implication being that Germany hasn't
seen enough of those contributions
elsewhere in NATO hazard decency and
dependability I would add honesty to
that since you're allowing so many
falsehoods to stay on the record yeah oh
let's not be silly please but let me say
that in fact the defence investment
pledges acknowledged to be made up of
several different components cash yes
indeed but also contributions and
capabilities and those come in many many
forms and in fact Germany is a very good
example of where they are putting new
new facilities on the table we need to
do a lot more on military mobility on
our ability to reinforce and they are
putting in place a new mobility command
in Ulm in Germany great example of how
they are contributing to the alliance
yeah so it's not the one-way street that
Donald Trump likes to claim it is Europe
contributes enormously to America's own
warfighting capabilities doesn't it
providing bases transport systems that
allow it to project force in other
regions where it wouldn't be able to
without those NATO facilities but that
again is never acknowledged is it and
you
never sound out for you what of course
we stand up for Europe because Europe is
know about Trump's falsehoods to stay on
the record well I think we have been
clear until he doesn't in telling it
like it is in the time we have left I'd
like to talk to you about the values of
this alliance medically in NATO's
relations with the Middle East and Gulf
countries yes in conducting dialogues
with them for many years NATO is up for
providing assistance it says to
participate in countries in the areas of
security institution building civil
military relations this is a very warm
NATO embrace for several brutal and
autocratic countries isn't it I'm
talking about Egypt Bahrain UAE with
very questionable human rights record do
you ever discuss the clear evidence of
human rights abuses in those countries
where are your dialogues human rights
free well by no means because in fact
when we work with all of those countries
they have the opportunity of somewhat to
pick and choose what we talk about but
we always bring our values to the table
whether we're talking about I mean
criticizing this building integrity
fighting against corruption ensuring
that everything they do in terms of
women peace and security is on the
highest standard we always bring our
basic values to the table when we talk
to any partner and when we work with any
ally and does that mean criticizing
their human rights records it means
working with them effectively that's not
the same thing is it I mean would you
discuss with Bahrain for instance their
continued use of civilian and military
courts to convict and imprison peaceful
dissenters or from the UAE which is
accused of maintaining a sustained
assault on freedom of expression and
Association I asked because they're
frequently here they frequently visit
NATO headquarters they're wined and
dined presumably but you don't ask any
of these unpleasant questions do you
well you're a cycle to an organisation
that purports to have failures you are
assuming a lot about what takes place
for one for one thing wrong wining and
dining is rather
where and how we interact with our
partners but what impact what in fact
does happen is that we portray the core
values around which this alliance is
built and everything we do with them in
a day-in day-out basis is meant to build
build the recognition and the acceptance
of those values in a kind of organic way
so of course the the discussion can't
take account of everything that is
happening day-in day-out in those
countries but it does focus on building
integrity it's good to have you on the
program runs got something thank you
very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]